[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
the biggest moment
aside from the actual sentence being
pronounced was when elaine maxwell made
a statement she made one heck of a
statement a sentence is handed down for
convicted sex trafficker elaine maxwell
and a missouri mother stands trial for
the murder of her daughter i believe her
words were what am i supposed to do when
my daughter throws herself in a fire
plus she will tell you about what was
going on in that house
how christian wasn't being fed
he wasn't being bathed
he wasn't being cared for dwan ferguson
did not kill his son here opening
statements from both sides as dejuan
ferguson is tried for murder and later
scott peterson is due back in court we
look ahead to the convicted killers
coming court date law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer months
after she's convicted of federal sex
trafficking crimes elaine maxwell is
sentenced to 20 years in prison
law and crime network covered maxwell's
federal trial closely as the companion
of jeffrey epstein was convicted late
last year federal prosecutors say
maxwell helped epstein groom girls as
young as 14 years old for sexual abuse
and sometimes participated in the abuse
epstein was arrested on federal charges
of sex trafficking in 2019 but was later
found dead by suicide in his jail cell
along crime network's michael bryant was
in the courtroom tuesday as the sentence
was handed down
there's a lot of build up you know it
was two and a half hours from the time
the hearing began uh and so a lot of
anticipation but the biggest moment
aside from the actual sentence being
pronounced was when elaine maxwell made
a statement she made one heck of a
statement uh if you didn't know better
you would think she was addressing you
know some of the highfalutin society at
dinner club uh she she acknowledged all
of the victims who gave very uh
heartbreaking statements as well uh she
acknowledged that uh epstein is an
animal and a monster and he manipulated
people bottom line is she came off as
hey i'm just one of you i'm just one of
the victims here uh and there was no
real remorse there was acknowledgement
of all the things that these folks went
through no real
real responsibility and that's key to
the sentence that was imposed because
the judge said
just before imposing that sentence
i saw no
responsibility being taken by this
defendant and the guidelines would have
given her somewhere between 18 and 19
years give or take so there was an
upward departure of sorts by the judge
herself and i really think she tied it
to the fact that this eloquent statement
that was made
that did not involve
any acceptance of responsibility for
what these these victims had gone
through
thanks michael maxwell was also
sentenced to five years supervised
release and faces 750 000 fined she will
be sent to a federal prison in
connecticut
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and criminal defense attorney adam konta
adam was the defense's request for jail
time a reasonable one should they or
could they have even done something
better
i don't think the request for four and a
quarter to five and a quarter years was
reasonable i mean when you look at what
her conduct is it's really really
egregious and the problem is she stepped
back to the kind of the defense her and
her attorney both did of listen we all
know it should be jeffrey epstein
standing here right now that's not a
good look in front of the judge just
take epstein out of it this isn't about
his conduct this was specifically about
your conduct you helped
traffic in minors for sexual contact
with adults end of story stop do not
pass go do not collect 200
four and a quarter to five and a quarter
was not reasonable 30 years also not
reasonable i think the judge really kind
of sent a message saying hey 15 to 19 is
the range i'm going to go a little above
that and i think the only reason she
went above that is because of her
refusal to take responsibility and
trying to pass it along to epstein yeah
maybe she didn't pass the buck and had a
bit of a different statement could have
gone a little lower there but that's for
another time to think about terry
hearing from both sides especially the
victim impact statements did the judge
come to the right decision in terms of
that number of 20 years
the judge definitely came to the right
decision here look she faced up to 55
years and the prosecution asked
basically for the max between 30 and 55
and then maxwell's attorney asked for
between four and five and which i agree
with adam 100 that's way too low to ask
for something like that this was a
serious crime the judge said it was a
serious crime she listened to those
victim impact statements she didn't
appreciate the fact that maxwell didn't
take responsibility and she said 20
years is sufficient and no greater than
necessary good decision yeah especially
when you think about it i'm thinking
adam of the who does four to five years
in state prison here in new york this is
way different i can't imagine that
number was requested but that's how they
did it thank you well just one day after
maxwell's sentence is handed down
disgraced singer r kelly is expected to
be sentenced on wednesday in federal
court lawn crime network covered kelly's
case last september when he was
convicted on all nine federal charges
against him including racketeering and
sex trafficking the r b singer could now
face life behind bars for his role in a
scheme to wreak to recruit women and
underage children for sex federal
prosecutors requested a sentence that is
quote in excess of 25 years kelly's
attorneys have asked for a shoulder
sentence of less than 14 years several
survivors are expected to speak at
wednesday's sentencing and kelly himself
may also make his first public statement
since he declined to take the stand in
the six-week trial law and crime network
will be at the federal courthouse for
wednesday's sentencing stay with us for
the latest developments in the case
also in celebrity news britney spears's
ex-husband is ordered to trial on felony
charges of stalking the pop star
this week a california judge ruled there
is enough evidence for 40-year-old jason
allen alexander to head to trial on
charges of stalking trespassing
vandalism and battery back in 2004
spheres married alexander her childhood
friend in las vegas the marriage lasted
for less than three days and ended an
annulment earlier this month spears tied
the knot for a third time to long-time
boyfriend sam asgary at their california
home
ahead of the ceremony alexander showed
up to the home uninvited and live
streamed the incident on instagram
spears a security guard says alexander
broke into the home and made it into
spears's bedroom alexander has pled not
guilty to all charges
still ahead on law and crime daily
opening statements are presented in
missouri where a father stands trial for
the murder of his son
but first a mother stands trial for the
murder of her teenage daughter how first
responders say she reacted when her
daughter's remains were discovered
[Music]
welcome back the first witnesses are
called in missouri as a woman stands
trial for the murder of her teenage
daughter prosecutors say rebecca rude
murdered her 16 year old daughter
savannah leckie back in 2017. savannah
had special needs and had previously
been adopted though rude's biological
daughter savannah was adopted by another
couple as a baby when she began
struggling with behavioral problems as a
teen savannah moves back in with her
biological mother rood and her boyfriend
robert p eleven months later rude
reported her daughter missing
prosecutors say rude abused savannah and
that she and pete eventually killed her
and burned her body in june of 2017.
investigators searched their ozark
county farm and found bone fragments and
teeth in a burn pile on monday pete's
father and an area fire chief took the
stand he described rue's response when
savannah's burned remains were
discovered
he said you're out there
maybe twice
i was out there the first day was your
important mission i don't recall if i
went back the second day or no okay
doing time you're out there searching
with those other folks uh the defendant
say anything about savannah's body being
burned on top of the hill no
and some other time after uh savannah's
remains were found burned on top of the
hill uh did you hear the time to say
anything about uh savannah what happened
to her that day
uh i believe her words were what am i
supposed to do when my daughter throws
herself in a fire
right so terry of course from the
defense and the prosecution there are
different versions of how the body was
burned how do you think that will affect
the jury's deliberations
you know it's interesting the defense
said during opening that rude was going
to say that this was something that
happened and then she burned the body
that she was going to actually admit to
burning the body so now we have evidence
that at one point she said that he might
have thrown herself into the fire first
of all that's not credible and usually
you'll have a jury who's going to be
looking at this evidence this is a case
where we have the judge who's going to
have to determine
what is true what actually happened
obviously i think the judge is going to
say
savannah did not throw herself into the
fire and i think the judge is going to
have to determine whether or not rood
was lying about how the body got into
that fire all right so adam those are
the different stories let's focus on the
one that we've got right here what are
your thoughts on rude's statement to the
firefighter when first confronted about
her daughter's death how bad are those
statements against her
well this is interesting because i think
the the most important thing to remember
here is that this is a bench trial so
you can spin a lot of things to a jury
that hey this is you know when when i
when i said this it really was in this
context and it's being misinterpreted
it's being misconstrued really this is
what i meant and it has an effect you
can connect with jurors a lot easier
than a judge
a lot of times so what they're going to
have to do is take this statement which
is seems patently untrue on its face
especially with hydrocodone in our
system and they're going to have to
explain it away
so to do that with a judge versus a jury
they're going to have to be very careful
and very smart about how and what they
say
to try to get rid of it which begs the
question should this have been a jury
trial but that will be a question for
another day
and then a monumental supreme court
ruling justices monday decided that a
former high school football coach in
washington had a right to pray on the
field after his games coach joseph
kennedy was fired by his washington
school district after starting a
practice of praying on the 50-yard line
at the end of football games kennedy
said the district violated his religious
freedom when they told him he couldn't
pray publicly on the field and asked
them to find a private spot the school
argued it didn't want kennedy's actions
to appear that the school was endorsing
a religious point of view but the coach
said he was acting on his own behalf and
expressing his own religious views in a
six to three ruling justices said he was
within his first amendment rights which
protects expression like kennedy's
justices who voted down the ruling
argued that school officials lending pr
leading prayer was constitutionally
impermissible and that the ruling did a
disservice to the nation's commitment to
the separation of church and state
coming up on law and crime daily for the
first time in years video cameras will
be allowed inside a scott peterson
hearing plus we head to missouri where
opening statements are presented in the
trial of dejuan ferguson
[Music]
welcome back opening statements are
presented in the trial of missouri
versus dejuan ferguson a man who stands
trial for the murder of his son a boy
with special needs who was last seen
nearly two decades ago back in 2003
christian ferguson was just nine years
old when he went missing while in his
father's care ferguson and christian's
mother theda were in the middle of a
custody dispute over the boy and his
sibling christian had a rare disorder
which prevented his body from processing
protein a condition which required
constant medical attention and made it
impossible for him to walk or even talk
investigators say ferguson failed to
provide his son with proper medication
for more than two years then in the
early morning hours of june 11 2003
ferguson left his home with christian
and stopped to use a pay phone he later
called 9-1-1 to report someone had
carjacked his running suv with christian
inside the vehicle was found just two
hours later about five miles away
christian's body was never found he is
now presumed to be dead in opening
statements monday prosecutors told
jurors what they will hear from several
of christian's family members including
his sister who was just eight years old
at the time of his disappearance
you will hear from lynn ferguson
christian's sister
she will tell you about what was going
on in that house
how christian wasn't being fed
he wasn't being bathed
he wasn't being cared for on the day of
june 10th
lynn notices
that christian's feeding tube
is not in his stomach
lynn was in her room she shared with
christian
christian is moaning loudly
she remembers pretending to be asleep
when the defendant walks into that
bedroom
picks up christian
and takes christian into the tv room
she hears christian moaning
she hears what she describes as a
struggle but she doesn't see it but she
hears it
and then she hears the moaning stomp and
then she sees dejuan ferguson
carry
a quiet christian and place him back in
bed
and then a short while later he comes
back in the room again
wraps him entirely in a blanket
and carries him out of the room
lynn ferguson never saw her brother
again after that
duane's defense attorneys argued to the
jury in their opening statement what
they say happened to their client's son
dejuan ferguson did not kill his son
in the early morning of june 11th of
2003
duan noticed that christian was sick
so when christian got sick
dejuan did what he normally did
which was to take christian to the
hospital
so he wrapped christian up in a blanket
because he was just in a t-shirt and a
diaper at the time
on the way to the hospital
dejuan realized he should have called
ahead when he realized his phone was out
of minutes
that's when he stopped at the pay phone
while at the pay phone dejuan left his
car running
and he realized his car was being stolen
as it sped away
dewan immediately got off the phone with
the hospital and called 9-1-1 to report
the car stolen
and that his disabled son was inside of
that vehicle
terry the prosecution said they filed
this case after a fresh set of eyes
reviewed it inconsistent stories from
ferguson and the fact that he stopped
cooperating did they do enough to start
proving their case in this opening
though
absolutely not they should have done far
more in the beginning listen the
prosecution has waited all these years
19 years 2003 was a long time ago and
granted there's nobody here it's hard to
prove a case if you don't have a body
but this was a nine-year-old boy it's
not like he went away on his own and
that story that someone stole the car is
bogus why do you have to stop at a pay
phone when you're going to the hospital
just go to the hospital if that is what
you are really doing so i think they
should have done the investigation back
then they should have done more brought
the charges they would have had the
witnesses and there's just no reason for
them to have waited all this time this
is the person closest to the child he
should have been brought to charges long
before this yeah adam maybe this was
child neglect and not an intentional
murder maybe someone really did kidnap
christian with different possible
defenses what do you think the defense's
opening suggests will we will hear
throughout this trial
i think it suggests that you're going to
hear a variety of options that may and
they may just try to decide what sticks
to the wall i mean what they should be
doing is listen
you see this guy dejuan you might not
like him he might not be a good dad has
nothing to do with whether or not he
murdered his son there is absolutely no
evidence that he murdered him they can't
prove this beyond a reasonable doubt
their burden to prove it hold them to it
and if you have even one single doubt
when this case is over which you will
have many your duty by law is you must
acquit him even if you don't like him
yeah i mean go with a bad dad argument
he's a bad dad but not a murderer we all
can't be adam cantos amazing fathers so
let's see how this defense continues
when we come back scott peterson is
headed back to the courtroom but not as
soon as planned what's causing a delay
as the convicted killer works towards a
new trial
welcome back closing arguments have been
delayed as convicted killer scott
peterson's team works to overturn his
conviction the hearing which was set for
wednesday is being pushed to a later
date
peterson's attorneys argue he deserves a
new trial based on a jury misconduct
this stems from jurors 7 in peterson's
2004 trial defense attorneys say
rachelle niece dubbed strawberry
shortcake by the media did not disclose
a past abusive relationship while
pregnant when answering a jury
questionnaire in a series of evidentiary
hearings earlier this year nice was
granted immunity in exchange for
testimony nearly 20 years ago niece was
part of the jury that convicted peterson
in the death of his 27 year old wife
lacey and their unborn son connor
peterson was originally sentenced to
death in the case but was later
re-sentenced to life in prison a hearing
wednesday is delayed until august after
peterson's attorneys tested positive for
cobit 19. peterson is also on a loose
quarantine after being exposed to covet
himself at san quentin
the closing arguments are now set for
august 11th
adam we know there's a delay but with
this decision for a new trial or the
coming decision what do you think the
strongest arguments are for the defense
and do you think they'll win with those
well i think they have a very strong
defense to get a new trial uh you know
jury misconduct is really really serious
and if it's tainted from the beginning
then that doesn't dissipate throughout
the course of the trial it only grows
stronger so if you know if you're
building a house and your foundation is
bad the house can be beautiful the
prosecution put together a beautiful
trial to convict him but the foundation
was bad because this juror made it so
and so you know they're going to rely on
that i think they're going to get a new
trial when they go back to trial i think
we're going to spend all this taxpayer
money to get right back where we are but
he deserves to get there the right way
yes the way the system is meant to be
done it's supposed to be a fair and
impartial trial for everyone regardless
of guilt or innocence well terry same
question for you but on the prosecution
side uh do you think the decision to
allow uh same question what are the
strong arguments but also i want to add
this other one what do you think a
decision to allow cameras in the court
well as far as the strongest argument
for the prosecution is concerned they've
got a difficult battle as adam mentioned
when you have during misconduct and in
fact that conduct might have affected
the deliberations then i do believe
there are great grounds to have that
conviction overturned and they have a
interview of this juror saying yes i
told the jury that you know they should
look at these victims because i was a
victim myself and you should believe
what these victims were saying so i
definitely think there's a good chance
that it's going to be overturned i think
the prosecution is going to have to
argue that it didn't affect the
deliberations but it's going to be
difficult to do that and i do think we
should have cameras in that courtroom
this is a case where it has so many
people looking at it and we need to see
what's going on
well sounds right well thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you